hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is Joshua fields Millburn
and I am Ryan Nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists welcome to episode
121 today we're going to talk about
emotions
oh man I've had an emotion filled week
the last week oh yeah yeah I was it was
a worry filled week last week Josh you
literally have two emotions that you
feel oh the other one is is
unadulterated rage but I just I keep
that all bundled up really tight it's
locked in that jar deep down in my cold
cold heart are you so emotional this
week no I've never heard you ever say
I've had an emotional week I didn't yeah
I don't I don't think I said emotional I
think I said I said I'm ocean filled oh
okay all right
but emotion filled yeah kind of emotion
no well that's that's that's what I
wanted to talk to you about before we
dive into the to the questions today so
we had two events this past week our
friend Courtney Carver was in town she
had a book come out called soulful
simplicity exert event yeah we were able
to give the intro on her event at our
favorite bookstore in the country it's
called the last bookstore it's downtown
Los Angeles so at that event we we gave
the the intro but but then we the big
thing this week was we had this this
filming we've been planning for months
and months and months for this event
dude all the stress all the anxiety now
I see what you're saying yeah all the
planning I we we would meet the
anticipation we were meeting daily to
practice and so over the last year we've
given this talk in about 50 different
cities the lessons now tour and we're
getting ready to finish that in
Australia but we wanted to take this
talk this 4550 minute talk and we wanted
the right aesthetics for we tried to
film it a few times at different
theaters and it looks great when you're
out of theater but it doesn't look the
same on film right it just looks like
you're in a theater so we found this
beautiful abandoned warehouse space but
trying down us with you I don't think I
ever look good on film I just like trust
Matt's creative eye alright well thanks
so what so when he says
dude we and when he said guys the
theaters aren't gonna work we have to do
something different I'm like oh okay I
just I just do what he tells me to do
well it wasn't so much about us looking
good or bad on film I think we're gonna
look pretty much the same no matter what
I think it just being a not appropriate
but I can't think of another word
besides appropriate I think appropriate
so good were appropriate for our message
like what is the the aesthetic that
correlates with our simple living
message and what we're trying to talk
about and so we wanted to create our
second documentary that really dives
deep on our backstory and and really
build it around this talk that we've
been giving and where we talk about
intentional living we talk about the the
the downsides of consumerism and
consumption in our own lives and
everything we went through in the past
and then we talk about how do we move
forward in a meaningful way how do we
contribute beyond ourselves and we
wanted a space that was right for that
but the most ideal space was an
abandoned warehouse and trying to have
an event in an abandoned warehouse that
isn't used as an actual warehouse
stocking stuff in there it's just a it's
for blank walls a ceiling and a floor
and then we had to do everything and so
podcast Sean and Matt they put in a ton
of prep work we had a production crew I
think of something like 20 or 24 people
and the snow was so weird dude Lake
we've never had that many people and
they're all there to help us create this
amazing thing right and it's so crazy
like being on this side of it it's like
it every time I watch a TV show now or a
movie or whatever it is and I see like
the the talent in in the the show I
don't think to myself oh who's that
actor or is it actress I think like man
what's the who's who's the producer
behind the who directed that what's the
production team because who's the key
grip yeah exactly I have a completely
different perspective on it because if
it wasn't for although that amazing team
right like this it wouldn't be anything
yeah the build-out was amazing I mean we
spent basically a day and a half I say
we I mean the team we had this empty
warehouse and we had to build a stage we
had to put all the chairs in there I
spend eleven hours on
lighting and then of course five cameras
and the directors setup and then you
have to get craft services for everyone
and we don't just have endless money to
throw at this thing and so it's like
Sean's like alright how do we get some
uh sure's in here for for less money
than what people usually charge we use a
service called yonder which is this is
the first time we've ever done it but
I'm like man maybe we should do this at
other live events we don't usually have
a very big problem but when you're
filming the thing I don't want someone
all of a sudden just start talking on
their phone or texting or even getting
and taking a picture usually it's fine
to take a picture during a live event
but when we're filming this but you
certainly didn't want all of a sudden
the phone ringing and someone talking on
it in the middle you know you're giving
your speech I didn't ask this but before
they so Yonder just for the people
listening it's a company you go to an
event they check your cell phone they
put it in a bag you get to keep your
phone with you the whole time but it's
in a bag you essentially can't use it do
they make you um do they make you put it
on in airplane mode before you put it in
the bag I think so hey moustache um I'm
Sean's giving me the nod yes okay see
either airplane mode or silent mode and
you could totally use your phone if you
want to use your phone there's just a
designated area where like you leave the
unlock and they're like great you can go
over here and use your phone exactly and
so just getting everything right getting
the sound right and you know everything
that is part of this event everything
had to go right and there are a million
things that could have gone wrong and so
of course I'm worrying about that and
it's making it hard to sleep the last
couple days of right before the event
and I'm just trying to figure out like
okay do we have this plan for well what
about this I can't believe I died ever
think about that and and man I can tell
you it all came together and it couldn't
nothing is ever gonna be flawless but it
couldn't have been closer to flawless
then it was yeah I yeah God you know
Matt got the footage he needed and
that's what I keep telling myself but I
get I feel like every event there's like
maybe two events I left and I didn't
feel wanting meaning I didn't feel like
oh man I should just said that
differently or man Ryan you sure did
ramble on that one question and so
wanting is it as an emotion so we're
talking about
motions here today wanting or desire or
craving is another way to show it's like
an intense one thing right and and I I
agree is like even when things go great
we want it to be better and when things
go bad of course we want it to be better
it's sort of part of the human condition
yeah and part of that is it's probably
good right otherwise we wouldn't
reproduce who wouldn't ever eat if we
didn't ever feel the desire to eat right
we didn't feel hungry then we just die
if we didn't feel the desire for sex we
wouldn't reproduce and there'd be no
people here anyway and and so it was a
worry field week but here's the thing
the relief which is also an emotion that
I felt afterward I mean max was like you
or not you won't stop smiling I call you
and I called you Sunday morning
I have never you've never answered the
phone that cheery never had to the phone
that year and I was like wow like
Milburn's in a good mood yeah I just I
felt so like relieved and and like this
tension was was just gone because here's
the thing with our live events we could
totally screw something up and it's
going to be okay because it's you we
dress spending tens of thousands of
dollars to film it right right if you
mess up a line or I literally trip them
on stage and fall over it's okay like
I'll get up and someone to laugh and
it'll be fine but yeah on film you want
it to be right it's never gonna be
perfect but you really want to put your
best foot forward and when we're doing
it all ourselves us and and this team of
people that we put together anything go
wrong and it's totally on us and we have
to take full ownership of that and so
after the worry though you you realize
like you didn't have anything to worry
about at all anyway because it all went
fine and that worry was part at least
mostly for not I think up to a certain
point the worry allowed us to plan
appropriately right but there was
probably an unhealthy amount of stress
or anxiety that I was feeling throughout
the week that that I didn't need to feel
it was the opposite of reduc that's
interesting an unhealthy amount of
stress because I feel like I stressed
out too but I don't feel like it was an
healthy amount I feel like I needed that
stress to help me keep a sense of
urgency YES on like practicing leading
up to the event on making sure to be on
time on places and in making sure that I
was fulfilling my end of tasks that I
needed to do to help with getting which
wasn't a lot but you know the this few
things I had it was important so so I do
think that stress is a healthy thing up
to a certain point but yeah so why do
you think why are you saying it was
unhealthy for you well I think I think
two reasons one is there's a healthy
amount of stress that tells it's an
indicator I should take some sort of
action but also you and I are two
different types of people you you thrive
in more stressful situations back in the
sales world it'd be the last five days
of the month and you're in seventh place
and all of a sudden you you finish first
out of all of the store managers for me
I would start the month off and try to
get set you the first 20 days I have
such a large lead that all of a sudden I
can feel good about the last ten days
and so I think we operate differently I
don't need that stress to make sure that
I practice I just needed on the calendar
I need the habit or the ritual right for
you the habit and the ritual can be
there but it's far more compelling for
you if you have a emotion tied to that
ritual yeah I've got this anxiety and
the anxiety to me it indicates like
leading up to the event
the anxiety indicated Ryan you've got a
practice today
you've got to make sure that everything
that you need to have scheduled is
scheduled the people that you need to be
there you have them showing up you're
double-checking that they're gonna be
there like that's what the stress does
to me it is because the what where I'm
going where I'm trying to go with this
is that eliminating that stress the
thought of eliminating that stress like
that is really motivating for me so
maybe that's why I operates so great off
of stress is because like the thought of
when it's gone like that is what
inspires me to push hard
does that make sense yeah but it's
ironic is
I know it's really weird they totally
make sense I totally get it and I feel
the same sort of motivation but I I will
do things to get rid of the [ __ ] almost
like I could just here pinch myself it's
gonna feel so good when I'm done right
why are you hitting yourself so it'll
feel good when I'm so good but you know
what that's all that's how I look at
like the the when we go to vote uh the
Russian bathhouse yeah that's how I feel
about the cold plunge dude like that
what keeps me in the cold plunge is the
thought of getting out of the cold point
how am i seei
you and I are the exact opposite I
actually enjoy being in the cold one oh
that's crazy yeah I can be in there for
5-6 mins people think I'm insane it's
like the more miserable I am in the cold
plunge the better it's gonna feel when I
get out yeah it feels good to me to be
weird man like that is it wig is it that
literally like the exact opposite
motivation well you've heard listeners
of this podcast sometimes refer to us as
the head in the heart right like I'm the
head of the podcast you're the heart of
the podcast and thus that's why you
could say I'm the intellectual side and
you're the emotional side and it's not
that you don't have intellect or reason
or I don't have emotions it's that those
tend to be our default settings to to a
certain extent Josh I want you to go by
the head in the heart calm uh-huh that's
a band is it really yeah I just said we
should rename this podcast head in the
heart when's the last time you cried uh
my cousin's funeral last weekend Wow Wow
yeah use 27 years old man did I mention
this on the last podcast no so yeah I
know he was 127 um past when expectedly
and yeah I did go to a funeral last
weekend that's about all I'm gonna say
about it because I really don't want to
dive into it too much just out of
respect for my family it's sure yeah
yeah yeah so so I have I think I've
cried twice and I can remember in my
adult life and and but it's weird
because and the reason I bring that up
once was when my mom died I know why are
you bringing it up Josh it's because
you're so manly no it's it's you want to
show
was in our audience how manly you are no
well here this'll this'll this'll remove
that right away I think I'm even told
back so so I think the last time I cried
specifically it was a few years ago but
and it was I was out of fear I I had met
backs and I hadn't planned on being in a
relationship i I I didn't want to be in
a relationship like I had gotten out of
one and like that it just okay I need
some time outside of relationships for a
long time maybe forever and and and then
I found like this most ideal
relationship when I wasn't looking for
it and I was falling in love really
quickly and it terrified me I was scared
to death because I didn't want to
experience the the the come down again
that I had with with the previous
relationship which I wrote about and
everything that remains I relationship
with Colleen and and man I didn't want
to go through that again and I remember
just laying there and realizing like oh
this is like this is the real deal in
fact this is better than any real deal
I've ever experienced and it wasn't just
the infatuation of the moment it wasn't
the ha the the honeymoon stage of her
relationship it was something different
it wasn't that chemistry is good our
chemistry is great but that was I wasn't
it it was something different I remember
just laying there and just like
literally one tear came out of each I'm
like I remember feeling this sense of
overwhelm and it was it was fear it but
it was also like of course I want this
and that's why I was afraid because I
did want it but here's the thing that's
what when you we talked about I Ryan is
the emotional half well why because you
show more emotions than me and when you
when you when you talk about we all have
a motion so when we talk about someone
who has emotions it conjures up all
kinds of images in my brain like if you
if you say there are really a most
no person if I were to say that abouts
are describing them I said yeah he's
really emotional what what what what
kind of images would that contra for you
uh that person is really dramatic okay
yeah and they might show their sadness
that person lower themselves from drama
the drama yeah
rage anger craziness you and I have both
had the privilege of dating crazy people
yeah that's true that's not a little
crazy myself sometimes I'm not gonna put
it all on the girls no no no not all of
my partners that's why I said people
right I mean I'll put the majority of it
on them and that's why I said people cuz
Becks and I were actually talking about
this this weekend we because I was
talking about the crazy person I was
dating right after my marriage the one
who threw scissors at me and and Becks
is like you are like really like filling
in the the the narrative for like the
crazy ex-girlfriend thing I'm like well
that's my only crazy ex-girlfriend it
just happens to be that I'm a
heterosexual male and so I date women
I'm sure if I dated men I would have
dated a crazy man along the way in fact
I think there's pretty good data to show
they're far more crazy men out there
than there are crazy women I don't know
Josh can we just can we just agree that
we're all equally nuts
no I will say we're all equally nuts and
Josh will agree that yes we are all
equal but here's the weird thing when
you say or when I say or someone says
he's a really emotional person or she's
really emotional what we often mean is
that sadness that anger that raged that
the the craziness but how come we don't
ever like mention the the other emotions
happiness is an emotion right sure
contentment is an emotion hope is an
emotion you don't describe a hopeful
person as emotional although if they're
really really hopeful then they're
really emotional yeah but all those
emotions you just brought up or like
they're pretty ambivalent so the problem
is that
though and when I say I'll think so what
about joy joy so when I say ambivalent
when I mean is that I could be in a room
happy and content and you you could
possibly not know it but if you were
joyous I'm more likely to know it oh
sure if I'm like jumping up leaping with
joy yeah absolutely
but you wouldn't say you generally
wouldn't say that's an emotional person
unless they were like overly joyous like
manic or something then that's an
emotional person but but have a person
who's just really kind kindness is an
emotion and you can you can only see
that they're kind if it's outward but if
a person is just kind we don't say he's
a really emotional person or what you'll
say you'll say that person is a receipt
that's Duchess it so if someone's really
kind you'll say that person is a really
kind person right and that person is
really loving man that person is really
and you'll actually name the emotion
when you say someone is an emotional
person that's where it's a pejorative
and why am I in my brain I think that's
the connotation I am I agree and I think
what we need to do is maybe reclaim that
because emotions aren't inherently good
or bad they're both good and bad right
and and here's the last one for you the
one that I was thinking about just now
is it you do see this outwardly because
it's a lack of display but calmness calm
is an emotion it's the opposite of
anxiety right if someone's really calm
you will see that they're really calm
but we don't say that person's a really
emotional person even though they are
and so I think maybe instead of us using
the term emotional pejoratively and
believe me I I am I am predisposed to
use that term pejoratively because I we
see how many times we can say the word
pejorative on this I think that was
twice no I started yeah I'm rejecting
sorry so I think that that the calm
person is equally emotional to the angry
person it's just a different emotion and
so maybe we can reclaim that so that we
aren't using that that word - we're not
using that word to discourage people
from embracing what those emotions are
we just don't want people to get stuck
in those negative emotion I think we
have to feel the negative
and the key then is to embrace the
valleys for what they are but get the
out of them as quickly as possible so we
can enjoy the mountaintop the the
calmness or the happiness or the
contentment or the hope or the kindness
that we experience once we've reached
once we've reached higher ground we've
got some questions here today also when
Courtney was in town
last week we dragged her into the studio
and had her answer a question or two
with us as well and so hopefully we'll
be able to incorporate that into our
questions this week Kaitlyn in st. cloud
has a question for us being a college
student I found that I was excited when
it comes to the hard standards that I
have I hold for myself not saying that
it's a bad thing but as until then
letting myself down I don't reach to my
full potential I'm going to come through
performance in the classroom and like
out of class work I'm holding these
ideas I often fall into overthinking and
stress myself out way more than I should
I am not sure how how I should go about
investing in these kinds of stops for
emotions do you have any insight or
advice for our can treat myself better
insurance performance and copy news of
my ability Ryan she's talking about
investing in these these thoughts and
emotions investing in stressed-out
thoughts and emotions I would never
invest in those so let's imagine you and
I we both invest in the stock market the
S&P 500 it's the most boring thing in
the world yes if you look at if you look
at it like index funds
you don't want stress and you don't want
to invest in the the index fund with the
stress and the anxiety what we were just
talking about the person who's
considered to be a traditionally
emotional person you don't want the
emotional person index right yeah
you want the broader emotional spectrum
you want to invest in emotion in the
emotions that matter now here's the
thing we were just talking about this
Ryan you were even saying this some of
these things help you out they help you
perform better the stress the worrying
especially if you are in college and
there are certain standards
and in fact she's experiencing anxiety
from those standards that's because she
wants to meet those standards and so
there's a certain level of stress that
is going to be useful
definitely no III think you know it's
funny I was with Jessica yesterday
Jessica Williams dropping off the
airport and I'd said something about how
we owe you you know how we always talk
about raising your standards lowering
your expectations right and she was like
she's like Ryan I gotta be honest with
you I don't understand what that means
so I do like explain to her what we mean
by that how do you explain she doesn't
understand what it means it makes me
think that maybe our audience some of
our audience doesn't understand what it
means so I had the way explained it to
her was I used our documentary as an
example where we put our absolute best
foot forward right we had this level of
standard that we were not willing to
forsake we want this to be outstanding
at least for us even if we can't I could
I can't predict whether or not fifty
million people or one or one other
person other than I can predict one or
half persons of me besides us right and
here's here's the thing if it's
outstanding for me it's my gamble that
maybe there are enough people with
similar interests and tastes and who
people who appreciate the same
aesthetics or narrative maybe there are
enough people like me now I mean
six-foot-two goofy-looking white guys
but people with with similar standards
who will find value in this absolutely
but if I if I try to go out there and
say well I really want this to appeal to
Canadians over the age of 44 and it's
like well I'm not a Canadian I'm not
over 44 like how do I helmet well and
it's possible but it seems a lot less
likely it's trying to meet someone
else's standards right and so having
your own standards was was really
important we were putting together the
film yeah and I think that that is you
know one of the expectations of the many
that we could have had with that film
who's gonna watch this the other thing
is is how much money are we gonna make
on this we did not have any we had no
a dollar figure in mind it was you me
and Matt who got together it was a zero
dollar budget and it was something that
we were really passionate about and we
said great let's create something really
awesome
and let's see what happens and to your
point we gambled that yes as long as we
had high standards other people will
find value in this and and could you
imagine dude like if we had this this
idea of expectation yeah this idea of
how much money we wanted to make from it
let's just start with that like that is
what a recipe for a letdown right right
um
you know unless it was like we're gonna
make 10 bucks off of this right even
then though because at first like we had
lost money even with the theatrical
release yeah it was because here's the
thing we had zero budget - broke even on
theatrical maybe no we didn't we were we
were still slightly behind but the good
news is that we made up for it on the
back end right and the reason we were we
were slightly behind is because we
didn't spend any money on producing this
film because Matt you know basically
went around the country with us and we
were already going around the country so
wasn't any additional dollars but then
everything on post-production the the
color grading the music the distribution
through theater all of it all added up
really quickly yeah I don't want to get
too far away from what I'm trying to do
with the the the raising standards and
lowering expectations what I'm really
trying to say is like with that
documentary because we had zero
expectations when we did get an offer
for theatrical release when Netflix did
decide that they want to put it on their
platform when people did go out of their
way to support us share and and share it
or or or purchase it on Vimeo that was
all gravy like that was all icing on the
cake it was like icing and sprinkles on
the cake yeah because we were not
beholden to any expectation yeah it did
not matter so applying that's a
Kaitlyn's question here Kaitlyn you
should she should have high standards
there's no doubt about it the
expectations I would encourage her to to
lower and what
mean by that is is that Kalin can study
for a test as much as she possibly can
and that's all she can do if she's gonna
worry about the expectation or I'm sorry
the result and have an expectation of a
really high grade that is going to add
in my opinion it's gonna add needless
stress it's the same thing with with the
event my with the special that we just
filmed my standard was really really
high and I knew that if I had high
standards and did as much as I could
leading up to that event it was going to
be the absolute best event that I could
possibly do and I feel like it was yeah
like I said earlier I felt a little
wanting like I just a couple little
things I wish I would have done a little
bit better but that's okay it absolutely
was it was it beat my expectations yeah
it absolutely beat my expectations Bo
that's because you had very low
expectations and going into it you had
high standards and and so if I were to
sum that up or or maybe just rephrase a
little bit different maybe the the
standards are the work and the
expectations are the goal the end result
and and don't worry as much about the
goal or the end result worried about the
the direction or the work that you're
putting in that it's going to get you
wherever you end up at the end of the
day if you put your best foot forward
you put in your best work then you're
gonna exceed remember expectation that
you could have had before but then those
expectations aren't there that because
here's the weird thing let's say all of
a sudden Caitlin your goal next year was
to make a million dollars you're gonna
make a million dollars next year but
then you only make $750,000 did you fail
yeah of course you failed you didn't hit
your goal out you didn't hit your
expectation 75% but that's a see ya
yes that's not very good right hell
$750,000 is is very good it's quite
often it's not just we have high
expectations we have the wrong
expectations we have unnecessary
expectations and we put them on
ourselves we also have other people who
put expectations on us and then here's
the third thing it's sort of an
amalgamation of both we think other
people have expectations of us
when they don't really the pressure that
we feel is it from other people the
pressure that we often feel 98% of it is
internal the pressure that we're that we
go around stewing with is is all self
created and because we turned that
burner on and it's doing we can also
turn that burner off yeah I think the
other thing I want to tell Caitlin too
is Caitlin
I've got good and bad news you're never
going to reach your full potential I'm
never going to reach my full potential I
really had to get comfortable with this
man like the again going back to the
special we just filmed it's like the two
or three things that I have in my head
that I'm like man I really wish I would
have done that differently if I would
have done this through through things
there probably would be another two or
three things that would replace those
two or three things absolutely maybe
good because we can nitpick ourselves to
death yeah and and and I think that's
actually a good thing I say it's good
news because I imagine if I ever reached
this self full self-actualization right
perfection perfection dude like this you
know when I think of what a perfect Ryan
Nicodemus looks like that it sounds
boring to me and it's not boring in this
sense of you know there's no there's no
mischief I can get into or there's
nothing else I can learn although that
is kind of boring if there's nothing
else to learn sure um but as as humans
like we we got to grow man we have to
grow we have to have we have to feel
like we are becoming something more than
our present self yeah and that's that's
a good thing Caitlin that you haven't
got to that perfect self so I guess what
I'm trying to say is realize that you'll
never be perfect and that's okay and all
you can do is get as close as possible
and pray that you never reach perfection
because when you do life's probably
gonna get really really boring and I
think that discontent that that Caitlin
is feeling in the moment I think that
can also be useful up to a certain
extent at least because this content is
a commentary on the present moment and
it's saying something going on right now
isn't right now what that is I'm not
sure maybe it's it can be her
expectations
could be absolutely in or or it could
also be her actions and she used this
word this word overthinking and it
stresses her out well let me just tell
you this because here's here's my
biggest problem Caitlyn is I often try
to think my way out of problems you just
can't do it I would say that's about
half the work yeah it like getting the
Ryan getting the right mindset in the
right perspective right it's half of the
work but but the problem with me and
with a lot of people is is it it ends
there we're the thing I'm gonna ruminate
my way out of this issue right I'm gonna
use the law of attraction to make this
happen I have had this conversation with
people where we're like they're just
super firm believers in the law of
attraction and an eye-to-eye believe in
it but it's not the end-all be-all
meaning that you the the main problem I
have with folks who rely solely on the
law of attraction is that they're
missing the action piece of it yeah
which is is the most important part
because you're right we do have to have
the right mindset we do have to use
reason and intellect and mingle that
with emotion and really what the law of
attraction is is is focused right
there's an old a Pathan wherever focus
goes energy flows and all that really
means is whenever we focus on that's the
direction in which we're going but of
course if you turn your car east but
don't start driving east you're not
going to get to wherever you're going in
the east right yeah and so Caitlin you
can't think your way out of a problem
and so that that means sometimes when we
want to change our or the way we're
feeling change our emotion emotion we
have to change our like our physical
state our physicality and so the other
thing that I often think about is motion
moves emotions the other day I was
feeling really stressed out right before
our our LA event and in that taping and
so I and I'm just like oh man I've got
this headache and I'm trying to deal
with this and I've got all these things
to do I need to go take two hours and
and really create some physical activity
for myself so where our studio here is
about 10 minutes
away from Runyon Canyon I just took that
10-minute walk to the trailhead and just
busted my butt all the way up to the
ridge line and I mean it's gorgeous but
I'm breathing hard I'm feeling better
all of a sudden it's like this stress is
is leaving my body because I can't focus
on it anymore I can only focus on what
my body is doing right there when we
push ourselves it's a different kind of
focus and and it changes our focus from
these negative emotions that are keeping
us down that we're overthinking and all
of a sudden we can come back to the
problem with a with a renewed mindset a
fresh pair of eyes and maybe approach a
little bit differently with with without
the stress or at least with with less
stress than than what we had before and
also uh she said that she's meditating
right now here's the thing meditation
does help the problem I used to get
caught up with is I when I started
meditating I'm like well man I did this
two days I did over a whole weekend
twenty minutes yesterday and 20 minutes
today you're so good at meditating I
should have figured out by now but I
don't all my problems are solved this
obviously isn't working well it's the
same thing as with going to the gym you
know our friend Dan Harris says that
that meditation is like going to the gym
for your brain and I feel that way like
you can just go to the gym Saturday and
Sunday and bust your butt really hard
actually for 20 minutes each each time
but I I'm fit now you don't get fit over
the weekend right right you in your
brain doesn't retrain itself over a
weekend or a week or a month or even a
year it takes a long time for you to get
physically fit it takes you a long time
to get mentally fit to improve to see
these incremental changes and so I think
Caitlyn meditation will certainly help
you out if you do more of it and also
one of the meditative things that you do
it could be going out for a walk I could
be doing yoga it's not exactly
meditation but there are meditative
tasks for me it's it's walking just from
here to wherever I like to have a
destination in my universe just walk
into the post office to mail a letter I
will walk three miles to the post office
and back because I have a destination
right there yeah my favorite is like
walking to the office because it's about
a four mile walk
and it's about hour and 20 minutes and
15 minutes I am forced to like not think
about anything because like my whole
point is is like I get to the office
gonna record a podcast like the the
point is that is the walking and it
forces me basically to not I don't think
about anything else I got put my ear
pods in and get going and have an
amazing relaxing walk yeah yeah and it
doesn't have to be relaxing if you want
to do something to really push yourself
you can do that being in the sauna as a
way for me to push myself and that is
meditative for me in fact I it's a
meditative experience but I also
meditate in the sauna it's the place
that I prefer to meditate because it's
harder do you really have to focus and
it's like it's it's training your mind
on a different level it's like you can
do yoga or you can do hot yoga you can
do meditation or you can do hot
meditation and it does force you to
focus a little bit more the last thing
that I'm thinking about here is this
word flap ability our friend Cullen
Wright has this essay that he just put
out we'll put a link to it in the show
notes but I wanted to read about it
because he talks about you I think when
I think of our friend Colin he was just
on our podcast recently he is he's
pretty stoical and his approach to most
things right it's something he lacks
emotion but he's able to employ emotion
appropriately when the situation calls
for emotion he wrote this essay about it
it's called flap ability there's
something to be said for a stoic
response to difficult or uncomfortable
situations to be more specific it's nice
to be able to step back and assess
things from a mental distance to
recognize and acknowledge what's
happening but to address it from a place
of calm rather than a state of emotional
fragility to recognize that you can't
control what's happening to you but you
can control how you respond to it so
what we're talking about here is yeah
most of the time it's good to be able to
step back when we feel this crazy
emotional response mm we should be able
to step back dude this is so important
for Cailin because she is so worried
about the result
she is so worried about the result that
she cannot control like the the the aula
study and she puts into it she's worried
that she's not gonna get the right
result mmm
but to your point the only thing she
can't control is how she reacts to the
result yeah and so maybe the best way to
regain control is to give up some of
that need for control yeah I'm yeah I'm
yeah going back to the lowering and the
expectations because I think
expectations is a form of us trying to
have control we expect something it
happens we feel good about ourselves
because that means we're in control
right right and so I'm gonna skip ahead
in his essay quite a bit so long as I
encourage everyone to read it it is it's
all my favorites from him that he's
written recently he goes on to say that
said there is a potential downside to
this approach to dealing with the often
unpleasant variables with which we come
into contact throughout the day it's
possible to rationally assess a
situation only to realize afterward that
perhaps emotional immersion would have
been the better approach in that
particular circumstance you can look at
a beautiful sunset and recognize that
it's beautiful that the colors are
amazing that the weather is perfect and
that you care deeply about the person
standing next to you as you both look
out together at this wonder of nature
that's a very valid and valuable flavor
of enjoyment but because of that mental
air gap between you and the moment it's
not exactly the same thing as pledging
headfirst into an emotional response to
what's happening you can enjoy a sunset
stoically but it may be more prudent in
terms of full exposure to everything
that's available to you in the moment to
dive deep as you dare into what you're
feeling rather than calmly and safely
floating along the surface and so I
think what Colin is saying here Ryan is
yeah we should often have a rational
approach to much of life and that gives
us the ability when we need to have our
emotions there to jump all the way in
you don't want to just go to a sunset
and say you know that looks like cotton
candy in the cloud I mean you can say
that and there's an intellectual sort of
side of it as well no matter why you're
always going to have a mixture of both
unless you're
robot but but the truth is there are
moments where you could just want to be
in awe of the moment and I felt that the
day after we finished the the the taping
in Los Angeles and we filmed two
different events that day well two and a
half really cuz we had to redo the intro
to get a micro that was great so so the
we had to go out and go give the whole
intro once again and at first I thought
that was totally going to ruin the
moment
right seem to enjoy it more like man you
did better on the second intro it's like
you knew what we were going to say yeah
that was that was good though man yeah I
thought I went really well and here's
the thing afterward Ryan I plunged
headfirst into the emotions that I felt
the the relief was I was a totally
emotional person with the emotion that I
felt most was relief and contentment and
and those were the emotions that I let
myself experience instead of saying I
feel like I have accomplished this task
no and and I do feel accomplished but in
a way that is that has lent itself to
this content because I'm I'm happy with
the standards that we put forth and that
we were willing to put in all of that
work and in the payoff that came after
that from putting in all the work there
wouldn't have been the payoff without
that work absolutely it didn't come from
the expectations we had though it came
from the standards that we had and the
work we were willing to put in yeah man
we didn't just sit around and think
about how great the events gonna go like
we we put so much prep work into it man
yeah we didn't really pay it off
you didn't think our way into a great
event for Caitlyn there's a mindfulness
chapter in our book essential it's an
essay collection 150 different essays
about intentional living there's 12
different chapters on 12 different
topics one of those topics is
mindfulness Sean if you could reach out
to Caitlyn and get her the audiobook
version of that if you like this podcast
you're like the audiobook version of
essential or if she'd preferred the
physical book or the e-book were happy
to give her one of those as well and
before we move on to our next question
we dragged Cortney Carver into our
studio when she was in town last week to
answer this question for Caitlyn as well
here's the thing with Kaitlyn's you know
wondering how to invest in these
emotions you're gonna feel what you're
going to feel but I think the problem
comes in when we start judging ourselves
for how we feel so we feel anxious about
feeling anxious mm-hmm and that's a
whole nother layer of not really
treating ourselves well so she also said
how can I treat myself better I believe
in that question and so when she's
feeling that anxiety instead of the ho
judging for being anxious turned to
self-care what can you do that might
make you feel good like you taking a
walk for me often it's writing down
whatever I'm feeling because sometimes
if I can get the emotion out of my head
and onto paper I can see it for what it
really is and sometimes it's just
completely useless but I can't
understand that unless I see the words
on paper our next question is from Ryan
in Kansas City my father committed
suicide in 2015 in direct response to
the federal government seizing his
belongings and because of that that's
kind of what threw me into this
minimalist lifestyle um and has kind of
given me this anger towards maximalists
or towards people who exhibit
materialistic behavior and I was just
kind of wondering how do I let go of
that like how do I not get angry at
people that don't want to get rid of all
of their things and I realize that it's
not for everybody but I find myself
getting almost resentful towards people
that in my opinion value their stuff too
much which I know like isn't okay so I
just I guess I wanted to know what you
guys do to both avoid getting angry at
those people and also to in the most
caring and loving way possible help
guide them towards a minimalist
lifestyle
first off Ryan I'm really really sorry
to hear about your loss i i've been
obviously through the death of a parent
twice both of my parents have had passed
away my father when I was really young I
was nine when he passed away I didn't
know him very well
he left us when all my mom left him when
when we were I was like three or four at
the time I was almost four and I saw him
one other time seven years old around
Christmas and he died when I was nine
and I mean I talked to him on the phone
occasionally and so we didn't have a
really close relationship but as a kid
you know you you look for a father
figure and I was lucky enough to
actually get an adopted brother when I
was right around that age and he was
very and physically he was very who's a
year older than me and but he was he was
almost like a father figure for me but
uh at least in terms of physicality was
a really tough guy and so I I remember
just growing up with him having a
brother who was also a father figure in
my life and then and I think that helped
me out a lot but then one mother passed
I was 28 years old and we didn't have
the best relationship until I was in my
twenties she was she was an alcoholic
and and it made growing up really
difficult but we repaired all of that
throughout our 20s and and when I was 28
she passed and it was a definitely
different circumstance from what you're
going through but let me just say this
he likely committed suicide not because
of the government seizure government
seizures don't make people commit
suicide
because government seizures happen every
day what happens when people harm
themselves or kill themselves as they
feel despair despair is a commentary
about the future it means I don't think
things are going to get better
and here's the thing we all feel despair
many of us get trapped in despair we
feel a particular kind of pain and
that's because our basic needs are met
or we have a roof over our head we have
food we have clothes on our back but our
psychological needs
are not being met and when our
psychological needs aren't being met
quite often we we turn to things that
harm us whether it's the ultimate harm
which is killing ourselves or I'm from
Dayton Ohio it's the the overdose
capital of the United States it's a
great city I love that city but there's
a lot of problems going on there and
Montgomery County right now and it's
because a lot of people feel despair and
why do we feel despair well we've lost
this sense of purpose or meaning or joy
or contentment and we feel like there's
no hope for the future and what is the
answer though well I think it's it's
restoring meaning in some way well we
don't have a suicide crisis as much as
we have a crisis of meaning in our lives
and I think we can change that by trying
to find ways not through the same
repetitive means of yesteryear because
here's the thing if your dad would have
gotten his stuff back
would he would he feel all of a sudden
that his life was fixed and there was
hope on the horizon no probably not he
would have felt comfortable enough to to
continue on a life that was still
peppered with despair and so I think
what we need to do is we need to find a
way to inject meaning and that meaning
is never through our things the things
have only the the meaning we give to
them they can help us be comfortable for
sure I'm not against consumption we all
need some stuff you'll never hear Ryan
and I say get rid of all of your things
and follow us that was someone else but
what we will say is you're welcome to
have stuff but the more meaning you give
to it the less joy you'll get out of the
the less creativity you'll get out of
life the less the less you'll be able to
do because you'll be so tethered to the
things that aren't bringing the real
purpose joy and meaning and so I think
the anger that Ryan is is feeling here
not the Ryan across from me but the Ryan
on the phone I'm so angry
Ryan's angry because I just keep talking
no let me talk to you I think I think
the anger that Ryan is feeling is an
anger toward consumerism you you said
you're ain't you're angry toward
maximalists or you're angry towards
material lists and I don't think you're
angry at those people you're angry at
the behavior and what I've realized it's
you can love those people even if you
dislike their behavior you don't have to
be angry about it though you can dislike
the behavior because judgment is but a
mirror that reflects the insecurities of
the person who's doing the judging so
all you're really saying when you see
the the behavior of someone else you're
saying I don't like that behavior
because it's not an appropriate behavior
for me and in our documentary Juliette
sure she she mentioned that the problem
with our society isn't materialism and
the problem is that we aren't
materialist enough right we don't give
we don't give and we don't care enough
about the things we bring into our life
but the everything becomes disposable
and then of course we care too much
about clinging to the things that aren't
adding any value and and we're not
willing to let go because we don't see
that someone else might be able to give
value from that and so here's what I'll
say for Ryan is some of the the emotions
that you're experiencing are useful
right III think that the useful emotions
help you grow but they become useless
when you hold on to them too tightly so
if you're feeling angry toward anyone
who owns stuff then it is just a sign
that yeah you need to be willing to let
go of that emotions not so that you can
forgive them or whatever but just so you
yourself can move on you have to let go
so that you can move on absolutely Ryan
I think you need to continue to talk
about this anger you're feeling I'm
happy to talk about it with you I'm sure
you have friends and family that are
happy to talk about it with you as well
I would encourage you if you haven't
already to get a hold of a professional
and don't be ashamed in that when I was
in the corporate world I used to go see
a therapist once a week and Tony Soprano
totally inspired me for a second I'm
gonna say Tony Soprano was your
therapist
that'd be great though if he was you
just walk in James Gandolfini's in that
chair now a man like watching The
Sopranos and seeing him go to a
therapist every week to just vent out
all of his crazy stuff now he's a little
bit different because he had like
illegal stuff he had to talk about yeah
and maybe it was a little too jail yeah
that's true but but you know what what
it really comes down to is that I think
a lot of people feel embarrassed to go
talk to professionals they feel like
somehow they've lost that life because
they don't know how to deal with their
problems or they feel like you know it's
embarrassing to like ask someone for
help right yeah
so again Ryan I'm I'm sure you've
already done this but I know there's
someone listening to this who has that
stigma there is no reason to not talk to
someone who has experience in talking
people through these emotions the other
thing I'll say to man is I'm not
personally I'm not gonna waste my life
being mad at other people's actions
unless it harms you directly well yeah
then oh yes if Sean were to reach over
right now hit you in the head with a
microphone I'd hit him back in the head
with a microphone wrecking our
microphones guy with tit-for-tat no um
but you know what I'm saying man like
when I see someone who's a maximalist or
I see someone who is a racist or I see
someone who whatever insert you know
someone that I would never associate
with in my life there yeah
like getting mad at them is not going to
help them it's not gonna help me it's
not gonna help anyone around me
laney and even even so if you find a
person who's racist and they're harming
someone else even getting mad at them is
probably not going to solve the problem
as much as other things will solve the
problem a calling the police on them
stopping them from doing something that
harms someone else is better than just
lashing out in anger right here I think
that there's a John Mayer line this is
the John Mayer line segment of the
podcast where we we inject the wisdom of
Jhansi Mayer
to go into the podcast that he talks
about has on the continuum continuum
album when he said has a sign and it has
a sign ever changed anyone's mind and I
think about that quite often with with
bumper stickers or protest signs or
whatever I've never had my mind changed
out of someone else's anger right now
can a pithy saying or something may be
influenced me in a way made me think
about something that isn't think about
before yeah or maybe yeah there's a
funny sign that makes me laugh or
something that's fine but but really
with with with these emotions that were
experiencing most of the time man it's
just it's just not useful and man it we
have such a hard time letting them go
though and I think that's what her
ultimate question is how do I let go of
that anger right yeah I totally agree if
I had the magic bullet answer on how to
let go of anger I would certainly give
that to her right now I've got one for
you know so I've got a really really
short essay from Seth Godin he has so
Ryan and I we often talk about ignoring
the sunk cost like you've bought some
widget that used to be worth 500 bucks
but now it's worth $50 and you're like I
can't let go over that 500 dollar item
it's not a 500 dollar item it's a $50
item sell it while you can still get 50
bucks for it right well Seth Godin has
this short essay called ignore sunk
clowns yes there was supposed to be a
clown at your birthday party no he
didn't show up that's a bummer but but
your friends are all here and the sun is
shining and you've got cake in a game of
pin the tail on the donkey ready to go
the question is how long should you
mourn the loss of the clown how much of
your party are you ready to sacrifice
the same question confronts the pro
golfer who 3-putted on the 3rd hole or
the accountant who forgot an obvious
deduction one that can't be recovered or
the salesperson who missed a key meeting
or the speaker who got let down because
the tech crews screwed up her first
three slides if it doesn't help
I bathe in it when we can see these
glitches as clowns as temporary glitches
that are unrelated to the cosmic harmony
of the universe or even the next thing
that's going to happen to us they're
easier to compartmentalize that happened
okay now what so maybe your anger is
just a sunk clown it's just a clown that
happened you're angry about it
now what and I think I think Ryan if you
ask yourself that it's gonna help you
deal with the anger it's gonna help you
let go now what do I want to continue to
carry this with me you're gonna fill up
your your backpack full of anger or you
gonna choose to fill it with the
emotions that are maybe a bit more a bit
more helpful in that essay he said the
question is how long should you mourn
the loss of the clown how much more of
your party are you ready to sacrifice oh
so here's here's the answer for Ryan in
Kansas City the party here in this
metaphor is the rest of your life how
much more of your life are you willing
to sacrifice to anger and despair and
regret and and when you ask it that way
you're like I don't want to I don't want
to waste any of my life to anger and we
think about it a little bit more
rationally we can realize oh I can let
that go I can feel it but I don't have
to wallow in it I can walk through the
valley I don't have to live there I love
to send Ryan and Kansas City a copy of
our book everything that remains in that
book I talk about dealing with my mom's
death and sort of the process of going
through all of that it's there in the
third chapter and and and having to walk
away and not just from her but but her
stuff and and Ryan we got this this
question on Twitter this week this guy
said that his his mother was or his
father who had stage four cancer and
he's trying to like deal with his death
the best way he can he asked for some
advice and my advice for him was help
him let go help your father let go
because in helping him let go
you yourself are going to be able to let
go yeah absolutely
hey man I think Courtney has something
to say about this too
I don't even know if it's really anger I
know when I find myself being mad or
judgmental or feeling a certain way
about what other people are doing it's
almost because I don't want to address
what I am feeling so I'm wondering if
that anger isn't a bit of a distraction
from being sad hmm and I know it's been
a couple of years but this is just
something you don't get over immediately
and so to be able to divert her
attention to trying to fix other people
or wondering how to do that she doesn't
have to face what she's really feeling
which could be deep sadness so I don't
know because I don't really know the
situation but that's sort of what I'm
thinking all right we'd love to hear
what you have to say so if you have a
comment or tip about emotions including
advice for any of our callers today
leave us voicemail four zero six two one
nine seven eight three nine you can also
email a voice memo right from your phone
to podcast at the minimalists comm where
our favorite comments and tips on a
future episode Ryan what time is it it's
time for our lightning round where we
answer questions from social media we
are on Twitter and Facebook and
Instagram at the minimalists during the
lightning round this is where Ryan and I
both do our best to answer each question
with just a short shareable less than
140 character response we also put the
text to these minimal Maxim's in the
show notes so you can copy and share our
pithy answers on social media if you'd
like and you can now find all of our
quotes all of these pithy answers that
we give some of which are helpful over
at minimal Maxim's calm all right our
first question is from Debra how
important is it to take emotion out of
big life decisions or should you let
them guide your process well I have two
little pithy answers here for you the
first one was almost a joke at first but
I think it's also true when you talk
about taking all emotion out of
important life decisions so here's my
first pet the answer emotions are like
[ __ ] everybody needs them
and you think oh I mean there's the
opinions are like [ __ ] everybody he
has or whatever yeah but uh yeah but but
I think it's true of emotions like we
actually need emotions and and I think
they're an important part of of the
decision-making process right and so I
think you want this is my second pithy
answer
let Reason guide you but let emotions
inform your decision so so let the the
reason in your life the intellect the
the the pros and cons list let it let it
guide you but you also have to take in
account emotions because you can say
here's my pro and con list here are the
17 reasons that I should move to
Saskatoon but if you get to Saskatoon
and you're like man this doesn't feel
right to me you don't feel the right
emotions about the place you're pro and
con list doesn't matter because
Saskatoon is a great city we've been
there but if it doesn't feel right to
you just doesn't feel right to you in
fact there are a lot of places we've
been on tour where I'm like I really
like this city but like it wouldn't feel
right for me to live here right and and
so we you you have to keep those
emotions in mind when you're making a
decision just don't let them don't let
them guide your every decision I think
that's when you get into trouble you
sort of turn in that balloon who is if
you if you if you blow up a blue and
just let it go I do this to ll sometimes
it sort of chase it around it goes
everywhere right
that's how mote emotions guide us right
yeah definitely the intellect is the
string on the balloon well it's funny
because I think that I think that as the
heart of it it could be it could go both
ways the string can also be the emotion
because sometimes intellect it is taking
out the emotion this is why people refer
to us as the head and heart right
because let me give you an example let's
say that and let's say I was let's say
that I let's say you were a really
hardcore annexe hardcore alcoholic
and if I drank alcohol in front of you
it made you feel like you wanted to have
another drink and it wasn't offensive
but it's just
not the it's not great when you're
around someone drinking especially if if
I'm sitting there getting drunk right so
what I would intellectually I can look
at it and say it doesn't matter what
Josh thinks it doesn't matter you know
what's going on I can get drunk if I
want to like it's not that big of a deal
emotionally I look at it and think man
you know what Josh really needs really
need some support right now and I'm
gonna put my I'm gonna put that
intellect aside and I'm gonna put that
emotion first yeah oh yeah it sounds to
me like your approach is very
intellectually right now yeah which in
and I think what you're going through is
is I think I guess what I'm trying to
say is that into the intellect in a
situation like that it's a in my opinion
it's the wrong thing to let guide you
know I think you were letting in that
particular scenario you're actually
letting the intellect guide you because
the first thing is I don't care how he
feels I feel how I feel but then your
your intellect jumped in and you rely
well no I think this is the right thing
for him because it could you know
trigger him to going back to drink
you were actually taking a very
intellectual approach I but that said I
do agree with you that sometimes there
are some decisions where emotion is
going to to rule the day and I think
that's okay till yeah I think when I
read this question the first thing I
thought was don't ever make any life
this major life decision under distress
so I mean that is an old a Pithom that
I'm sure most people have heard it's a
saying for a reason right so to answer
her question head on don't make any
decisions but when you are when you are
any major life decisions if you're under
a lot of emotional distress the pit the
answer I've written down here is it
doesn't matter what you let guide you as
long as your actions align with your
values and beliefs man how many times do
we talk about values and beliefs Josh
yeah yeah I think that that's that's the
key here right like you're growing you
know that emotions and intellect are
going to be involved in these decisions
mm-hmm is the direction you're going and
align with the person
you want to be yeah and honestly men
like the values and beliefs for me it
helps me to use the emotions or or the
intellect yeah then they become
different it's sort of the flap ability
thing we're talking about Colin right
earlier it allows you to use both when
they are effective mm-hmm yeah for sure
absolutely all right our next question
is from the motivated stoic why is being
emotional stigmatized while so many of
us desire to feel good yeah I mean I
think that's thing we were talking about
the top of the show right the reason
that emotional is stigmatized and I'll
give you a pithy answer here in a second
but the reason that it's stigmatized is
because we think of an emotional person
as a person who's out of control with
negative emotions and that's why it that
they are stigmatized but my pithy answer
is some stigmas are useful other stigmas
are a byproduct of fear so choose your
stigmas wisely and so let's think about
some useful stigmas here right I think
debt is bad
I have stigmatized debt I think racism
is bad and thus I have stigmatized
racism there are other there are other
stigmas there are other emotions that
are are not useful right so jealousy I
will stigmatize jealousy as well because
I don't think there's ever for me in my
own life there's never a time that being
jealous of someone else is useful
because that means I'm living up to
someone else's standards not my own
right I'm letting someone else's
standards or expectations or preferences
dictate my life and so I stigmatized
jealousy is choose your stigmas wisely
yeah yeah man I had a different I had a
different suite of will answer down here
I'm not gonna read it now it just made
me think the the pithy answer I had pop
in my head now is the only stigmas that
matter are our own and yeah ultimately
if we let other people's judgments
control the way we feel especially when
it comes to emotions like that's if we
can't be ourselves then that it's gonna
be that's gonna make for a miserable
miserable life I think the one thing too
is emotions are like think about someone
who's depressed think about someone
who's who's angry he's asking about guys
specifically right or he's asking about
people in general
yeah but regardless if you think about
those types of emotions like those are
the people that we don't want to be
around like I don't want to be around
someone he's always angry I don't wanna
be around someone who's always depressed
certainly I want to support people in my
life who may be experiencing things like
that and and help them yeah you want to
help them get out of the negative moterz
oh yeah here's the thing you're not
judging them for experiencing those
negative emotions when when your cousin
died and you're you were feeling sadness
you know I just reached out to you said
hey there's anything I can do let me
know I want to help you through that I
don't say hey man why are you feeling so
sad today
that's silly right but I also want to
recognize that being in that valley for
too long is a dangerous place to be in
yeah I'll help you get out of it if you
need that help yeah no I think
ultimately emotions are stigmatized
because of people's insecurities man
like they're like anyone who's like ho
ho I can't believe the gosh crying or I
can't believe that guy is showing you
know any type of emotion like that's
usually a that's an indicator of what
that of that person's insecurities yeah
they're they're wearing their
insecurities well right right all right
Joe well oh yeah added-value let's talk
about some added value Ryan this is the
the portion of the show where we talk
about something that has added value to
our lives recently I've got two things
one is we've developed a new friend in
town here I had a lot of like health
issues of course the last three years
but we moved out here last I don't know
two months right after our Nashville
event I got sick and I needed to get an
IV can I say that I didn't even know
before you that if you were sick you
could pay a doctor to inject you with a
with a bunch of vitamins and it's
basically
it's like it's like emergency or
airborne but times 100 it's directly
into your it goes right your bloodstream
as opposed to having the process of via
the liver and yeah and your stomach and
and and who knows what's your gonna make
it actually into your to your
bloodstream then into your body without
just getting you know relieved into the
toilet right you means a lot of the you
buying some of those vitamin C packets
or whatever from the store that's a lot
of that just ends up in the toilet right
yeah because your body just when you
ingest it it takes what it needs and
gets rid of the rest right and and
sometimes some people's bodies aren't
don't do as good of a job taking what it
needs right right and and and so a lot
of it just doesn't go into the body at
all but if you're able to so I I've had
a few IVs here recently there's this
place in Hollywood called Metro MD it's
just Metro dash in the.com a guy dr.
Ryan Greene who is he's brilliant he
mean he went to his residency was at the
Mayo Clinic and he's from Chicago moved
out here and and wanted to really focus
on the Wellness side of things and
preventative because he realized that
being and this is the reason you didn't
realize I can just go to a doctor and
get an IV to to really help me your
replenish and get well soon or right
it's because most of our medical system
doesn't focus on the preventative side
of things it it per it focuses on once
you already if you tossed a grenade into
a Honda Accord and then you take it to a
mechanic the mechanic is like and you're
like hey can you put this back together
that's what our medical system does like
because we are putting grenades into our
bodies basically or at least the
equivalent over many years many decades
and then by age 60 all of a sudden it's
like here's your exploded Honda Accord
whereas he wanted to so dr. Ryan green
over Metro MD he really wanted to to
help people beforehand I think we're
seeing more and more of this now people
doctors and in this industry starting to
change focusing on wellness focus on
preventive preventing disease and then
also optimal health and so you and I
both went and got IVs a few days
right before the we even though we were
we were perfectly healthy
we wouldn't got IVs a few days before
our events okay we make sure we don't
get sick over these next few days your
immune systems are operating at its full
capacity as possible exactly and one to
feel good about it you also got a blood
test there and and yeah well because my
cousin passed away so suddenly and it's
I mean if it lives like oh wow like I'm
36 years old and if he would have got a
blood test might have saved his life
yeah absolutely and so when you think I
heard Tim Ferriss say something about if
you're getting your oil if you get your
oil change more frequently than you get
your blood checked then you're doing
you're doing something wrong and here's
the truth we're all doing something
wrong then because most of us don't get
our we don't get tested that frequently
but we probably should right and so I
mean I think to get a blood test once a
year at least I have the last few years
now and just to see you where are your
hormones or what are your indicators
yeah do you have anything that's out of
whack and because if you check it that
allows you to realize like okay here are
the things I need to adjust maybe I need
justice in my lifestyle maybe I need to
take some sort of supplementation when
my gut was really messed up I didn't
know why but when I did the test a few
years ago it's like oh you have c-diff
and that kills 14,000 people a year in
the United States
I should probably fix that but if I if I
wouldn't have known that I wouldn't have
known how to fix it but once you realize
you have that then you can figure out
how to fix it doesn't mean it's easy to
fix it I got my blood tested last year
and for heavy metals there's a totally
separate test from what you got but I
got tested for heavy metals it was like
oh yeah you have really high levels of
mercury and arsenic and and lead is not
crazy to high but it was high enough
strontium was really high and so it was
like okay now you know this is high you
can do something about it here's a
protocol and again not easy but it's
better than being in the dark and then
10 years from now all of a sudden I am
on death's door because I've I've
completely ignored all the issues and
the signs that have been going on and so
I encourage people to obviously if
you're in the LA area I think dr. Ryan
green is a great place to go he's a
great guy yeah he came to our event this
this past weekend
and he was he was in he walked into the
the the back where were our green rooms
stuff were and our booking agent that
was there Andrew Russell and I'm like
hey doc and he's like who's that guy I'm
like oh he's just our doctor he's like
you mean he's like a doctor on TV I'm
like I don't think he's on TV but he's
definitely like he's just all-around
great guy he knows a lot about health
and and and he's man I I'm really
grateful like when you find the right
people and you bring them into your life
I think it helps improve your life we
hear that old platitude of you are the
five people you surround yourself with
it's also true 150 people you surround
yourself with and I'm grateful that
someone like like dr. Ryan green is is
in our circle so it's funny like because
I think about when I chose my
chiropractor my I got this from you'll
remember his name Tim Ferriss interviews
him a lot um kind of a like an older I
think he's Russian trained like all the
Olympic athletes yeah Pavlov suelen
that's him
he talked about how important it is to
have a chiropractor and how he's like if
you have a if you have a chiropractor
that cannot deadlift as much as you
that's not the right chiropractor for
you interesting it's funny cos like I
and I just so happened like my
chiropractor that I had in Missoula yeah
and actually my chiropractor now could
absolutely deadlift as much as me but I
think about that as it with a physician
to like you know it's funny when I go to
a physician and like the physician is
looks unhealthy right and they're
telling me how to be healthy now I
understand that there's a difference
between giving advice and taking advice
in fact I know very well about that but
what's awesome about Ryan green is like
because he is so healthy right it's like
his advice I'm like I want to be just as
healthy as him right any part of this he
has great genes but here's the cool
thing you do too and and I don't but
whatever you can you you can go down
that path and and you can get similar
results right you may not get the same
results as as you know the as actually
his name's Pavel Pavel Tatsu one
and you may not get the same exact
results but you're going to get similar
results and you're gonna get better
results then I agree with you man you
don't want to our friend Karl our mentor
both of our mentors he we saw work with
him in the corporate world he would
always say don't ask a guy who makes
twenty thousand dollars a year how to
make a hundred thousand dollars a year
great I think the same thing is true
when it comes to your doctor I used to
go to a doctor back in Ohio who was
unhealthy as hell and I'm like well wait
a minute I'm thinking about now and
retrospect like what why did I trust him
just cuz he was nice and friendly but no
he prescribed a bunch of nonsense to me
quite often and I wish I would have
found someone like dr. Ryan Greene over
a metro MD sooner or wherever city
you're in yeah just go get your blood
tested see what's going on with your own
life if you get your car checked up
occasionally or maybe when you're
getting your oil change you just realize
I should probably also get my body
checked up at the same time if you're
gonna get your car checked up Ryan is
there anything that's adding value to
your life recently yeah man how did you
like that recreational coffee it was
really good so the it was the brand is
actually called recreation yeah right
now III made a Becks a cup a couple days
ago in the morning she goes oh my god
this is coffee so good where'd you get
it from she's like checking out the bag
and stuff and they're in Long Beach is
that in Long Beach yeah I was up there
doing Global Entry Mariah and I had like
these global entry interviews yeah and
just on a whim I was like man really
want a cup of coffee afterwards
interview and just stopped in got a
Yirgacheffe pour over of course yeah v6
there I don't think it'd be 60 and then
like as soon as I like took a sip I was
like oh my god I have to buy these
beatings yeah thanks man appreciate ya
know where is it but they I'm
recommending it because they sell their
beans online so I think the last
recommend I know I had a coffee
recommendation on one of the podcast
recently might have been the last one so
that was with Blue Bottle Columbian this
one is recreational it's an Ethiopian
Yirgacheffe that is specifically like
the best roast that they have going on
if you can find a link to that well
we'll throw it in the show notes along
with everything else we're talking about
today I'm gonna cheat and add 1x
bonus added value I just found it this
morning Ryan and it's really good new
artist she's 15 years old which is
unbelievable how talented she is her
name is Billie Eilish and I found so she
has this album out that just came out
toured I think they're at the end of
last year it's called don't smile at me
it's the way I can describe it is you
know the artist Lorde mm-hmm right so
Billy Eilish is from Los Angeles Lorde
is from New Zealand I believe so Lord if
Lord had you mixed her somehow with lisa
hannigan do you remember lisa hannigan
she was Damian Rice's sort of side
singer I mean she was she was always
with Damien Rice back in the day so so
talented all right well it's time for
right here right now where we talk about
what's going on in the lives of the
minimalist so we got some stuff going on
we're headed to Australia
we're headed to person Adelaide and
Brisbane and Sydney and Melbourne and
Oakland most of those are sold out are
really close to selling out actually let
me take that back
Melbourne is sold out we added a second
date for that Perth Adelaide Brisbane
and Sydney are all really close to
selling out and then we have a vent in
Auckland as well so if you can make it
out that's March come on out see us the
minimalists calm slash tour for all the
dates theatres tickets all that fun
stuff we've got a video version of this
podcast coming soon so if you want to
subscribe to that head on over to
youtube.com slash the minimalist we'll
do a regular video version of this we'll
also do some other video creations
whether that's video essays are little
snippets from the podcast more condensed
or attenuated creations videos just for
you over there on YouTube also if you
want the show notes to this podcast and
every episode that we put out we can
send them right to your email just head
on over to the minimalists comm enter
your email address there at the top
we'll send you the show notes whenever a
new episode comes out also any essays
that we write that will show up right
there in your inbox and of course will
never send you spam or junk and will
never give your email address to anyone
else because only awful people do that
oh and if you want to support this
podcast you can do so a few ways you can
do it head on over to the minimalists
comm click donate at the top you can
support us one time on PayPal or venmo
or if you want to become a regular
supporter of the podcast you can click
on patreon over there you can become a
patreon supporter those are the folks
that will help us build this beautiful
new studio that we are in right now and
every week on patreon we publish a
postscript episode and what that is is
we answer additional questions from our
audience just for our patreon supporters
now I know what you're thinking man I
don't want to log on to the Internet and
listen to a podcast on the internet
that's stupid
do you log on to the Internet yeah yeah
are you still using AOL yeah I have some
exciting news for you I go ahead have
you ever heard of zoom town 68k no way
alright so people don't have to log onto
the internet and I was through podcast
you don't have to get on your computer
or on some website or whatever whatever
podcast app you're listening to this
podcast on right now we do a separate
podcast every week called the
minimalists private podcast and it is
just for our patreon supporters and so
right after this comes out usually the
day after we do I post a script episode
where we answer questions we're able to
let our hair down a little bit more
because there's only a few thousand
people over there who are our patreon
supporters also on patreon this month we
have released our Philadelphia events
Tampa events and Detroit event we had we
had a guest at our Detroit event that
was Colin right and so you can check
that out it shows up also in the
minimalist private podcast feed so that
all shows up right there if you're
listening to this on overcast or Apple
podcasts or feedly or whatever you're
listening to it's right there on your
phone it shows up all you need is our
private link we've got some other live
events coming soon just for our patreon
supporters you also get first access to
any tickets to any new live events that
we announce in the future if your
patreon supporter you get the best
tickets in the house before anyone else
has access in the general public and
also a last thing that's coming on
patreon pretty soon is a studio tour of
this new studio space once we get the
way
lighting to be installed and some some
new furniture to show up here we're
using a little temporary table and some
temporary chairs right now but you'll
get to see that really soon we're going
to do a video studio tour on patreon
also we do live streams every month
where we answer your questions it's
called ask the minimalists anything and
that is exclusively for our patreon
supporters head on over to the
minimalists com click donate at the top
if you're interested in that I want to
thank Courtney Carver for being a part
of this episode this week check out her
new book soulful simplicity we'll put a
link to that in the show notes Ryan you
got anything else for us heck yeah I do
man look at all these voicemail comments
and tips from our listeners bring it hi
this is Tracy from Madison Wisconsin I
am calling in response to the podcast
about social media is wonderful and
there's so many things in there that I
have struggled with and thought about
and I wanted to share that over the last
maybe six weeks to two months my
relationship with social media has
drastically changed because my intention
with it has really changed mainly I'm a
kidney donor and I started really
speaking up about it and trying to
educate people and becoming a resource
for people who were curious about it
because there's so few out there because
it happens that almost nobody talks
about it and it's been so rewarding and
that almost well every week a new person
or even more than one person will
contact me about donation and it is most
rewarding way I have used social media I
also talked about finances which was
actually spurred from the budget podcast
by the minimalist and I have gone like
hell-bent on paying off debt not using
credit cards and I now have this ripple
effect in my social network of other
people that are doing the same thing so
it feels good to be intentionally
spreading the good and sharing the
things most people don't talk about and
seeing really positive results and even
richer and more positive connections
coming back from that hi my name is Tex
and I'm from Seattle one thing I haven't
heard mentioned on the show yet is
minimalist eating this is where you eat
as few yet healthy ingredients as
possible I do this for breakfast lunch
and snacks a handful of nuts two
hard-boiled eggs glossy milk a cheese
stick and apple or a protein bar are all
good examples not only is this healthy
but saves me loads of time throughout my
day in the evening I do
spend time on a quality meal and enjoyed
that food and I mean let's be realistic
here but the point is a spinning effort
on simplifying your food gives you more
time for your day and quality nutrition
hi this is Anson feller up calling from
Salt Lake City Utah responding to your
episode about decoration I'm the
designer and frequently helped clients
navigate through the process of creating
an intentional home and in this process
I avoided trends at all cost if we
really look at what trendy design is we
see that it's designed to encourage
consumerism companies are motivated to
make products that will eventually go
out of style
so I direct clients to architectural and
design history to inform the style of
the home quality is just as important
and function as it is in design alright
so that's it for this episode if you
have a question for the minimalists give
us a call for zero six two one nine
seven eight three nine you can also
email a voice memo to podcast at the
minimalists comm and if you leave here
with just one message we hope it's this
love people and use things because the
opposite never works thanks for
listening y'all we'll see you next time